nearly 40 years ago utah's great salt
lake covered about 3 300 square miles
today it has shrunk to less than
one-third of that size
the demand for water is outstripping the
supply of water to the great salt lake
now what used to be a safe haven for
wildlife and an industrial powerhouse
for the region is a looming ecological
and economic disaster in utah and across
the world the great salt lake is an
economic engine for this region we know
too many
examples around the world where terminal
lakes have dried up and the outcome has
not been good the shrinking lake might
seem like a local issue but its
dwindling waters have economic
consequences far beyond utah's borders
we'll explain why
[Music]
the worst case scenario for utah's
shrinking great salt lake can be seen
600 miles southwest at owens lake bed in
california owens lake dried up decades
ago decimating the local economy and
producing some of the worst levels of
dust pollution in the united states
according to a 2020 study los angeles
county ultimately spent about 2.5
billion dollars in dust mitigation
efforts great salt lake is 15 times
larger the cost is going to be
exponentially more
utah is now raising to prevent the same
outcome for its great salt lake even as
more water is diverted for agriculture
human consumption and industrial use
what has happened since the pioneers
first came here is they started
diverting water from the rivers that fed
the great salt lake so the amount of
water that is being diverted from these
rivers has increased
exponentially
and is going to do so into the future
because our population is booming more
recently this problem has been
compounded by severe drought and higher
temperatures throughout the american
west
but then there's a secondary factor
and that factor is climate change
because climate change here in northern
utah
is changing the whole hydroclimate of
the region
now industries that depend on the great
salt lake are being forced to adapt like
the mineral extraction industry which
accounts for about 1.3 billion dollars
in annual economic output according to a
report commissioned by the great salt
lake advisory council magnesium
potassium and lithium are found in
world-class concentrations in the great
salt lake joe havasi is the director of
natural resources for compass minerals
one of the largest mineral extraction
companies on the lake
it produces key ingredients used in
lithium-ion batteries for electric
vehicles
it is also north america's largest
producer of potassium sulfate a
fertilizer required to grow high-end
crops like fruits and nuts what we do is
we draw brine in from the great salt
lake into large open evaporation ponds
in the evaporation ponds the water
evaporates leaving beds of crystalline
recoverable minerals
this process contributes to lower lake
levels too accounting for about 13 of
total water diversion the lake is also a
critical resource for the manufacturer
us magnesium a company that is the sole
provider of primary magnesium metal in
the country
so if you hold a soda pop can in your
hand or if you go sit on a stadium
bleacher that is made of aluminum the
magnesium in those cans and in those
stadium bleachers comes from the great
salt lake
lower lake levels have already forced us
magnesium to move a pump station to get
water to its evaporation ponds
other companies around the lake have had
to expand their canal systems which take
complicated permits and cost millions of
dollars a dwindling lake would also
reduce available jobs so broadly the
mineral extraction industry on the great
salt lake employs over 5000 people so
there would be you know hundreds if not
thousands of of job losses associated
with that the drying lake is also
affecting an industry that is crucial to
the local economy and even your own
seafood consumption
45 of the world's brine shrimp comes
from this lake
and they're used to raise fish and
shrimp in aquaculture facilities around
the world
so if you go out to dinner in new york
city for example and you get shrimp
cocktail the chances that your shrimp
ate brine shrimp from the great salt
lake is very likely but as the lake
water drops its salt content increases
threatening the lake's brine shrimp
we are at a tipping point right now with
salinity levels for great salt lake as
we're starting to see a decline in the
brine shrimp population we're seeing
brine trip having a harder time
reproducing they're working so hard to
to shed the salt and just simply stay
alive the world-renowned ski resorts in
the mountains surrounding the great salt
lake are also bracing for changes in the
winter the lake benefits nearby ski
resorts by influencing the local climate
and weather producing lake effect snow
storms if the evaporation continues and
lake effect snow decreases utah's ski
season could be shortened costing the
industry up to 9.6 million dollars
annually
with lower water levels comes fewer
boats in the marina
fewer boats means less revenue for
recreation and tourism
people can recreate in their boats
anymore because it's a fairly shallow
lake and so they've had to dredge
in order that people can get out of the
marina into the water
and that has already cost about 1.5
million dollars
perhaps most alarming for the region's
1.2 million residents would be the dry
lake bed sending poisonous dust into the
air that millions breathe
a 2019 study from the university of utah
found that the lake bed contains arsenic
and other dangerous heavy metals much of
it residue from mining activity in the
region if the lake continues to shrink
the state could spend more than 330
million on dust containing mitigation
measures over the next 20 years
the best solution to
keep dust
down it's to keep water in the lake
there is no single fix for the great
salt lake's dwindling water levels
saving the lake would require letting
more snow melt from the mountains flow
into the basin which means less water
for residents and farmers
but salt lake city barely has enough
water to support long-term needs of its
population a report commissioned by
utah's legislature found that the
state's demand for water would outpace
supply by about 2040.
last december salt lake city stopped
issuing permits for businesses that
require significant water such as data
centers or bottling plants raising the
price of water could also help
conservation efforts
if you
have incentives like that to say well
we're going to increase your water bill
by you know 15
per annum in order to make sure that we
can save the lake
will people be happy with that will they
accept that in utah's recent state
legislative session lawmakers approved a
range of projects to protect the
long-term health of the great salt lake
this past legislative session was a
tremendous win for great salt lake and
we had over
500 million dollars in projects that
will be directly impacting great salt
lake and we're optimistic that those
will help us bring water to the lake
[Music]